erin brockovich became a household name
when a film about her fight for a small
town was released on the big screen
20 years ago starred julie roberts of
course and followed her role in a legal
battle against the utility giant pacific
gas and electric
for polluting the water supply of
hinkley california
in this clip brockovich demands pg e
fairly compensate
residents of the town take a look i want
you to think real hard about what your
spine is worth mr walker
or what you might expect someone to pay
you for your uterus miss sanchez
then you take out your calculator and
you multiply that number by a hundred
anything less than that is a waste of
our time
by the way we had that water brought in
special for you folks
came from well in hinckley
and the lawsuit was settled for hundreds
of millions of dollars that was a record
at the time
brockovich's fight for clean water
continues in a new book
that new book is called superman's not
coming our
national water crisis and what people
can do about it she joins us first on
cbs this morning erin thank you for
being here
uh this is an issue that all of us
should care about because the one thing
we all
absolutely need for life itself is clean
water
we were just talking in a prior segment
about a woman swimming in the hudson
river here in new york and i understand
you had a reaction to what we were
saying
i'm curious what was going through your
mind when you contemplate taking a dip
in the hudson um a couple of things came
to mind and good morning it's it's a
pleasure to be here
i did i don't know that i didn't think
you saw that i was kind of squirming
around because we have so many issues
with
sewage coming into our rivers and in it
uh you know there's moments where you're
like ew
who wants to swim in that but i did nod
at the
changes uh that they're making with the
hudson river and cleaning it up so
you know that's a good thing those are
the things that we want to see
yeah they have they have made some
progress that is something we can root
for but you know
a lot of people sitting at home right
now i can imagine them thinking you know
the water in my tap is just fine
but that's not true for everybody in
this country so i was hoping we could
begin by
giving people an idea of the scale of
this problem
the scale of the problem is probably way
much larger than they expect
yeah i'm the one that every single day
and we share in the book
of people that are turning on their tap
that have yellow water green water black
water brown water
water with pollution issues aquifers
contaminated their private wells what do
we do
where do we go and you know it's it's
still a shock for all of us i mean
looking back at 20 years ago starting in
hinckley
thinking that that was just a one-off
and that couldn't possibly be a
representation
of the united states of america we have
water problems
in every single nook and cranny and
corner throughout the nation
and we really are going to have to
this is why superman's not coming in our
national water crisis but what we the
people
can do about it and there's a lot that
we can do to begin to have
safer cleaner water in your own backyard
at your own tap
so why isn't superman coming and who is
superman
in in in the title is that federal
regulators health officials
you know um and we we weave with you in
and out of communities throughout the
book so you can see
you know it starts with the communities
and oftentimes that surprise where
they're like well the agency is here or
you know the department of health has
come out or the epa is involved in and
it will be fixed and
oftentimes nothing's been done or
changed and the look on their
face is really kind of shock
with the idea or expectation that
somebody
was there overseeing the water or making
sure that was safe
so it started with you know i'd have to
look at these communities and say but
superman isn't coming
but here's the thing that needs to
happen you're
here and you can get involved and i've
seen over time
when people know because oftentimes
that's the thing
they don't know what's going on they
aren't getting answers
that they get frustrated but think
someone's there that they start to
respond
so aaron if there's somebody sitting at
home right now on their couch and they
know
that the water in the tap in the kitchen
is not good enough to drink
what can they do what's step one to
changing that
usually the first step they'll take is
they'll end up emailing me and i believe
that they're looking for
support or am i on the right track when
they do email me
and i'm going to give them that
permission they usually are on the right
track
to make a phone call oftentimes we don't
do that to your local water provider
and look at your local water reports
we talk about filtration all day long
and if you read your report you'll often
find out there's something in there you
had no idea
was there to find out where it's coming
from
and then you can take more appropriate
measures and i encourage
all people who have water issues to get
in with their local city council
we oftentimes don't do that and we as
people
i think have a responsibility and an
obligation as well
to go let officials know or your city
council
hey this is happening because oftentimes
they don't so one of the first things
you can do at home right now
is pick up your phone choose to get
involved take an
action let your water provider know
what's happening
and from there if you don't get a
response go down to your city council
you'll get some changes made
yeah and aaron you're too modest to say
so but i would say another action
another step maybe step one
instead of emailing you by the book
superman
that's what it's called erin brockovich
that's why you're here thank you very
much for joining us we appreciate it
superman's not coming super thank you
superman is not coming but the book is
out it's available online today and in
bookstores on august 25th